das gemüse ist kein diesel oder herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft texte auf dem hero server ich
habe diese folge etwas vor und zwar
wollte ich mich mit dem iran wo bin ich
wo bin ich froh bin ich dass mein haus
und zwar wollte ich mich jetzt eine
doofe redstone roman ich hab' ich gerade
die ganze zeit über so etwas eigentlich
alles geht wieder recht habe ich gerade
doch irgendwas so war das doch etwas
dafür stellt weil ich außer sind einmal
gedrückt habe man eine ich habe mich
über dieses mallory dingsbums informiert
und zwar brauche ich aluminium was ich
dann also erst mal um euch das ganze zu
erklären dass sie es ihm wie der tank da
muss ich lange reihen füllen damit das
ganze in bewegung kommt hier muss ich
meine osr einfüllen also aluminium das
kreisen drin okay es ist aber scheiße
weil ich kann dass diese folge auch gar
nicht machen wenn da eisen drin das sind
dass jemand anderen gerät und da muss
ich schon fast neben der welt drin ist
dass es irgendwie noch flüssig keine
ahnung warum
und dass dann nach rechts drauf machen
dann kommt das flüssige reihen bla bla
bla bla so dass erst mal so große
theorie die praxis ist allerdings gerade
dass da was drin dass das deswegen
wahrscheinlich nicht benutzen kann und
ich mir wahrscheinlich einen eigenen
smart reading punkt bauen wollte und
dafür brauche ich ein paar blätter und
zwar mit blogs da frage ich mich
allerdings wo ich die hier bekomme weil
das irgendwie mit seinem komischen in
kiel gebaut wird reduziert briggs
irgendwas einfachste
zander und schaffe wer das ist geil
jetzt ein bisschen aus der stadt weg
auch vor allem weil ich gerade gar nicht
ausgerüstet bin ich hab nur die sachen
hier
ich habe mein schwert nicht scheiße und
ich habe auch kein haus wo ich mich
einbauen kann auch man das ist sie also
die sache ist wenn man hier so was
machen dann kommt er wieder leute darauf
und jetzt teleportieren sie gleich meine
start gut mein schwert es hier ja
wenigstens zweiter auf mich draufgehen
das bisschen kacke dann kann ich das
auch nichts gegen machen
ich kann mir einfach mal nimmst du schon
lange auf
3min bin nicht in der stadt
falls wir krieg wollte habe ich meine
spiegel vergessen ich könnte einfach mal
ein statt gelb gehen
soll ich mein statt gelb gehen auch man
jetzt ist das wieder so eine scheiße
folge hier man so gut ich musste mir
meinen spiegel kommen ich bin echt so
paranoid nennt vor allem wenn zander
alleine drauf hast du dein bester in
ordnung hält sind die beide darauf dass
halt ein bisschen scheiße ich will jetzt
auch nicht hingehen und dann meine
ganzen sachen wieder verlieren die stars
irgendwie das doofe gefühl dass die hier
sind was ein mensch apropos eine scheiße
man muss mein schoko da spinnt geschenke
welches im über grund
doch sie eigentlich aus hat er längst
gebaut nix so ich hab ich weiß nicht
soll ich da hingehen ich hingehen und
krieg provozieren ich habe immer so die
angst dass ich dann meine ganze sachen
verliere wenn die da zu zweit sind wisst
ihr
obwohl wenn ich doch mit soul täter
verzaubert hat wenn ich mit so thater
verzaubert hat kriegt die sache nach dem
tod wieder janocha oder ich weiß nicht
ob ich werde erstmal so aufnehmen wenn
die mich angreift alles in ordnung ich
bin ja ein friedliches ende friedliche
person hier
von daher ich habe angst wenn ich meine
sachen heilige jakob ossi die hat immer
als blamabler ist auch verständlich ich
will ja auch eigentlich keinen krieg das
ist also die sache gold äpfel sind im
kampf verboten aber nicht vorm kampf
glaube ich also im kampf um gold apfel
verboten habe ich überhaupt welche also
op gold april sind verboten ich weiß ich
doch diese brote die ich je hatte
da sind schon mal gold äpfel rpo habe
ich da noch gold abholen
hier noch garten ein so kleiner
fortschritt es wird blut kann ich dich
verzaubern irgendwie kann ich den
vertreibern
schade wäre cool wenn ich den auf folter
versorgung hätte können tun machen nein
ich kann jetzt auch eben eine pussy dann
mein haus einbauen aber da habe ich
jetzt auch kein bock drauf
oder habe ich noch nicht sogar noch
einen janes wort wie gut ich nehme noch
ein electric stuff sicherheitshalber mit
die wollen nicht eine golden carrot was
gibt mir denn genau für ein effekt ich
glaube man kann ich nicht endlich in
gold apfel rosen machen aus der passion
des porsche-sprechers beherrschen
splash pushen
ich habe keine ahnung ich daraus ein
special macht na gut
was hab ich denn sonst noch so viele
sachen die ich so diese sind dann nur
noch ihr wollt äpfel
ich bin da hab ich gerade gegessen
das habe ich hier noch als grenade die
haben wahrscheinlich sogar mehr herzen
als ich das könnte natürlich auch sein
und die sind zu zweit bestimmte gruppen
vetter golden wie sache
das hilft mir heftig fiel im kampf so
diese sachen kann ich auf jeden fall
hier lassen den kölner fortune auch mit
ex coach auch nicht den crystal bogen
nämlich mit den hier auch elektrik darf
ist auch wichtig was kann ich dann noch
annehmen
das machten dass hier irgendwas krass
das heftig was ihr da gar nix
er hat seinen sinn also was habe ich ihr
dann sonst noch so sachen die ich
gebrauchen könnte
eigentlich ich weiß nicht böse ich kann
einfach den pausenstand mitnehmen
diamanten bla bla bla bla bla stone
spielt nimmt es ist echt scheiße glowing
brett die habe ich nicht mal für das mal
mit keine ahnung was das bringt dann
kann ich ja mal austesten es hier noch
irgendwas dran was ich benötigen könnte
ich hätte fast das wichtigste vergessen
fall neda ist eigentlich nix ok ich wäre
bereit für den krieg aber wie gesagt ich
greife nur anwenden wenn wir jetzt auch
wollen
ich könnte ja mal einfach in der stadt
vorbei hier vorbeigucken ein bisschen so
kann ich immer in den spiegel benutzen
acht kämpfer sein haus zugebaut
das ist interessant dass er da dran safe
ist quasi das cool regal benutze ich in
meinem spiegel
statt geld wir können einfach mal
schauen was da los bei denen das ist
halt ein bisschen scheiße das 4 2 drauf
sind
das macht die ganze sache ein bisschen
ärgerlich
sind die denn wir könnten ihn sein ich
weil ich war noch nie so richtig in
statt geld
wer gar nicht wie die beiden ausgerüstet
sind ich glaube zander schon relativ gut
ausgerüstet hätten gar nicht zu hause
seid ihr zuhause
bei mir ist kalt alter mir ist ihnen die
richtigkeit nicht komisch das ist ja
eigentlich
unsere städte haben frieden oder ich
weiß nicht ob unsere städte frieden
haben nein
ok
nein quatsch
ich weiß nicht
da hinten hin dass einer den endmarkt
einer okay ich kann mal von einer
anderen seite
er ist ein echt kacke wenn die zu zweit
auf mich draufgehen würden
sie stehen lassen
richtig komische folge
das sander
sander kann ich zu dir kommen ohne dass
du mich willst also einfach nur so
eintreffen
das wäre cool dass wenn man eine erste
begegnung mit irgendwem statt gelber
ohne dass es zum krieg kommt
bilden verarscht
schenken jetzt ein brot was machen
sachen hast du zufällig aluminum für
mich ist das gemüse ist doch kein diesel
oder
bei den flieger sitzen hast du also wann
ich hab kein bock dass mit dieser scheiß
major events machen
halbwissen scheiß brakes er wagt es die
falschen
gibt er dafür irgendwann irgendwas
wieder ihr scheiß lama dieser ball nicht
im tor von apple der ganze scheiße
ok
ich komme jetzt einfach mal hinter dem
her schnüffelt puuuh er soll mir
aluminium geben da meine der hat ganz
viele
tander bitte bild
ja zwei stück aber nur weil es mal kirn
ist
ich heiße ich brauche vier bachmann das
recht wechselhaft geld kommt wieder hoch
bin am portal schaffe es auch schon
anders auch genauso viel gestorben wie
ich wenn ich relativ wenig gestorben
also wenn ihr zander geschrieben hätte
nein wir haben keinen frieden das
kämpfen oder so dann hätte ich gekämpft
das hätte ich mich ja nicht vorbereitet
ich habe ihn wie bock irgendwie schaffen
zu können
doch box hat das seiner gestorben
ich auch zu behindern
ich gehe jetzt mal durch
acht daraus hat den komischen wende
gemacht ach so es sieht interessant aus
die stadt von denen sie dann relativ a11
alumina aluminium mache ich dann mache
ich in gold obwohl medica nicht einfach
in dings reinpacken sexy danke
naja ist ja ist ja interessant also dass
wir so friedensvertrag habe ich hab
einfach so mittlerweile so mit relativ
vielen friedensvertrag so hier wohnt der
jeep das heißt hier packt wieder mein
spiegel verstanden blau aus nein dann
wäre es wenn ich mein rucksack vergessen
hätte dann hätte ich es packen können so
immer freunde muss jetzt gar nicht
suchen gehen hab ich einfach bekommen
naja gut so jetzt ich mach das jetzt mal
ganz kurz und zwar man mich regt es auf
dass dieser scheiß rufen hier so kacke
ist man die tatsache dass ich kein
aluminium haben krise kriegen und wo es
eigentlich meinen turbo schon wieder das
da oben irgendwo belassen
sie läuft einfach ein bistro geboren
nee ist es auch nicht
wo kann ich das denn gelassen haben das
kann dir sein wie heißt wie kann ich das
irgendwie rufen oder so manche aber auch
gemacht das ist date also stay als
königin alter ja gut am liebsten mich
das jetzt machen hier aber sondern nur
drei minuten
schade dass es darf ich mal eures
mallory gleich benutzen so da muss man
eben lover einmal mitnehmen backe backe
backe backe backe backe backe
dies von den partys a bucket das nichts
die haben da glaube ich noch was drin ja
bei uns halt drin
bei uns ist auch was drin
ja ich weiss nicht am liebsten will ich
mir selbst und ex-manager bauen weil
wenn ich öfter immer irgendwie was drin
und es ist ja auch ein bisschen doof
ich will doch nicht diese kg das ist
glaube ich einfach nur dass das flüssig
bleibt
und ich wollte diesen kreislauf jetzt ja
auch irgendwie ausgemacht kann mache ich
heiße es komplett ausgemacht verdammte
scheiße alter nicht dass das jetzt hart
wird opfer damit jetzt habe ich
irgendwas kaputt gemacht auch mano
entschuldigung von wem auch immer das
ist egal ich suche jetzt model habe hab
ich eben nein nein nein nein nein habe
ich nicht hier noch was
so läuft das hier heißt es ach so das
konnte ich hasse das wenn das irgendwie
so im suchmodus ist so darf vorne sein
chocobos talent ist nur ein bisschen
suboptimal wenn ein schoko buch nicht
ich habe keine ahnung wo das ist
schreibt immer wo das ist irgendwie
nicht das glas brauche ich auch glas ich
kann meinem alten haus die glasscheiben
einfach abbauen das wäre vielleicht
niebel sieht so ein 08 15 aus da hinten
dass ich nicht richtig traurig so habe
ich dann eine spitzhacke da mit cirque
touch
dann muss auch noch so ein komischer
andere holz kako wir sind schon längst
am ende erwartet damit eine solche
vielfalt sport die leichten aber noch im
abbauen die kacke die folgen den so
schnell vorbei diese 20 minuten im
megapark war es damals so janka kommt
man an ak 40 minuten am stück aufnehmen
oder soll aber diese 20 minuten geht
schnell vorbei oder ich mache es einfach
jetzt ebenso ich mache jetzt kurzen cut
und dann sehen was in der nächsten folge
wieder dann wenn ich auch auf die suche
nach aluminium gehen und die folge werde
jetzt halt direkt im anschluss an das
heißt an und schaffen werden
jetzt zeigen ob es euch gefallen hat und